hopefully it's a lot better than that
michael fassbender movie and yeah we
need to start doing that like making
film adaptations of movie novelizations
next I think that's words this is a new
genre people reject nation my name's
John who are you you're Anita Starr and
we are gonna check out don't don't lie
to the petrous you this is your
inaugural visit your name's Tiffany
forever Tiffany's on the Instagram go
check her out if there's a need a star
on there - probably but we are here to
check out some III trailers and guess
what party people there is a new
Assassins Creed on the way maybe it'll
reinvigorate my passion for this nice
black flag is that the one where you get
to play as Henry Rollins yeah it's all
set in like the punk days exactly that's
great well anyway we're gonna hop into
Sasa's creed Odyssey I don't know
anything about the direction this game
is headed I played Assassin's Creed 2 at
least back in the day my man ezio
jumping all over old-time Italy that's
actually not a joke I would just get
caught up reading while I played that
game cuz I'd always be like I want to
learn about Brunelleschi's dome while
I'm jumping high office tough time to
lay out the world and make you look like
the actual place so why not we'll join
us we're gonna check this trailer out
right now see what the present has to
offer here we go
David or if he to die Egypt
tell me Nicholas tell me before you let
our son go so good again 300 where do we
begin
does not define before you I see a BA
Wow bye Frenchy
[Music]
to protect its world
[Music]
you mean us act like it
oh it's right in
[Music]
you see
[Music]
of police
[Music]
you
another Spartans
Oh Assassin's Creed Odyssey watch the
official gameplay walk great that last
shot especially where it's just like
oscillating through the different
iterations wow that looks rad I mean
it's cool to live in the future because
video games look so much more insane
than they ever have in like just the
landscape saloner gorgeous beautiful
yeah well in the battle at sea like
they've gotten so much better at making
like water and plants that move like
real plants and just to go back to
ancient Greece for this one seems like a
really sweet I do
I already got imagine there gonna be a
ton of God of War comparisons in here
now the games are like that similar in
terms of how they play but anytime I
imagine a game goes to Greece you're
gonna get some Kratos name checks but
this doesn't give away much no I mean
this is really just like a taste test
for the look in the feel yeah more than
you know what the actual direction of
the story is gonna be what the context
is why you're plugging into this guy now
dedicate your life to Assassin's Creed
one basic yeah hey man eventually I feel
like if this game series is allowed to
continue on they'll just kind of do
every major time period in every major
region not an overly large amount of
context to draw from this aside from
just this setting and all that but that
alone makes me want to go check this out
and yes
joking about 300 and stuff during the
trailer but that kind of battle looks
really sweet to be able to do in a game
like this too because these games have
always had a pretty interesting and a
pretty kind of fun gameplay action
dynamic the various things you get to
scale and jump off of and then there's
combat and puzzles and stuff you don't
rely on like for games there's so much
you can do with knives and arrows I was
so in love with scream up until black
flash because the gameplay was so
different than what I was used to
well they do like throw the camera over
your right shoulder and you just kind of
button maps yeah I'm in assassin's creed
4 that's right it's really first burst
hey with the way VR is going is gonna be
like that and like 20 minutes that would
be moving the thing is I wouldn't even
want to fight anybody I would just want
to spend time hanging out just like
looking at everything that would make me
it worse for me to play this because
then I really would just go around
reading things be like oh wow can I go
inside kind of look at just ravines
filled with stones because that's how
badass the ancient Greeks really were
that's all I've learned is from 300 I'm
just excited to be able to stab somebody
with a trident that that makes me why
would I use a regular sword I got this
cool good line up well there are various
classes of different warriors and
gladiators again I don't know what that
last shot is exactly symbolizing whether
it's just you're gonna be able to go
through a bunch of these different
scenarios or if you're gonna be able to
choose your like one region to be a part
of or something to start out with but
certainly excited to see more going
forward from well get on that quit your
job stop helping the kids children what
children you don't work with children
haha that's good that's a perfect segue
what do you guys think am i a child
should I check out this game and quit
doing YouTube and just play video games
for the rest of my life let us know in
the comment box below and as always guys
you can subscribe
- the real rejects hit that notification
bell to get updated every time reviewer
of videos out because the subscribe
button doesn't do that you know what was
you got a it's a you know you got to
feel like you did some check out Olivia
on the instagrams forever Tiffany's not
temporarily Tiffany's forever and we're
on patreon as well if you love us come
on over there we got music video
reactions full-length TV show reactions
Q&A is every week a lot of fun stuff
would love to have you and as always
Cheers